- Hello Believe Nation!
It's time to pick the
winners of the book contest.
(techno music)
All right, so I was excited
the day is finally here.
A lot of you submitted
some amazing entries.
We're going to do a giveaway
of 10 autographed books
with a customized message sent directly,
potentially, to your house.
A lot of you entered in
with some cool stuff,
and I actually had Nina pick the winners,
so if you are one of the
winners, you can thank Nina
'cause she's the one who picked you.
And if you're not one of the winners,
you could blame me, 'cause
I asked Nina to do it.
That's leadership, right?
You give away the glory,
you take all the crap.
So if you liked it, give
a shout out to Nina,
and if not, you can hate on me.
So here it is, our 10 winners, good luck!
- Okay happy Monday guys.
I'm Nina.
Evan's not home right now.
He asked me to record
the book contest video.
I hope I will do a good job.
Bear with me guys, okay, so
I look over all the videos,
the links that have been sent in,
and I have picked my top 10s.
The first one, I picked Rhonda.
Rhonda has been around for a long time.
I saw a lot of her
comment, I really like her.
I pick her, it's not because I like her,
well, yes I like her, but
I pick her because she did
a really good job off the videos.
She not only make one
video, she make two videos.
She talk about her one words,
stand, and also she laid out
why she she picked the one word, stand.
So, she spend a lot of time and effort
and really good video, thumbs
up, so that's my first pick.
Actually, the order does not matter.
It's not like who did the
best, who did the least,
but this is my, that's
what I have in my notes,
and these are the people I pick.
Second contest that I pick is Zeno.
Zeno, I love you!
You've been here for a long time as well.
You've been around.
You always in Evan's gratitude video.
Whenever I'm there, I see you there.
Thank you for the support.
Evan loved your supports as well.
So the reason I picked
Zeno's video because he has
a fireplace in the background.
I love fireplace, just so you know.
Whenever we go camping
always I could just sit there
for an hours, hours watch the fires.
It's very calm and soothing,
but, yes, it's good video,
and also Zeno laid out all
the importance of finding
the one words, and people
could hate it, people could
love it, so and he talk about
to embrace it, so it's good.
I like it, very good.
The third one I pick is this girl, she,
her one word it's optimism.
She's very like Evan, once she
has a mindset for something,
she goes for it.
She told a couple of her personal stories.
So the first story she
was telling I, when she go
on a field trip, she told
her classmate she want to be
in that school, and she ended
up she went to that school,
so it's very like Evan's.
And, I also like her plant.
I'm a big plants person, so she has a
jade plant in her video.
I really like it.
And she told me that her
plant has once bloom.
Hmmm.
I want to know how.
For the fourth one, the reason
why I picked the fourth one,
it's because it's a teen entrepreneur.
We got to help teen entrepreneur.
For most of you who watch
a lot of Evan's video,
he has told the story
about him and her sister,
when they were kids,
like when her sister was
three years old or four years
old, they went out to sell
some kind of arts, I could be wrong,
I don't remember, but they did that.
Oh, the fifth one, this
is actually very creative.
I really like this one a lot.
It's actually art, the one where book pour
into electronic device cell foam.
I really like that, very creative.
Good job, guy.
The sixth one that I picked, this guy,
he actually got a One Word book.
When you open it, it's blank.
Nothing is showing on the book.
He show his top 10 favorite
quotes from the book,
so very good, I really like it.
So the seventh one that
I pick, this video,
it's a teaser video off the One Word book.
It's very cool that he made a
teaser video and it's teasing
the audience that, oh,
you should read this book.
I like it.
Okay, for the eighth one, I
got to pick this one because
it has a Teemo character on
the bottom corner, and Evan,
when he plays League of
Legend, he always pick Teemo,
and Teemo's one word, it's 'shroom.
Very funny, very creative,
I really like it.
I say I really like it a
lot, but I do, I like it.
It's very cool, very funny.
Thumbs up.
The ninth one that I pick,
it's a very funny picture.
This guy who's sitting in the cold water,
it's a winter time, and he's
out there reading Evan's
One Word book, and he wouldn't
go in because he needs
to find his one word before he go in,
so it's very funny.
Good job.
So, the tenth one, the tenth one I pick,
it's very funny, actually.
Christina also sent a email
to Evan said that, this video,
she has to be one of the top 10 picks.
She design cakes, she made two cakes.
One is Evan's One Word
book, and another one
is the Believe logo, and
she'll be sending these
two to Evan, but I'll be opening the two,
so I really like it.
Mmmmm, yummy, cakes, my mouth is watering.
So these are the top 10 that
I've picked for the contest,
but I do have two bonuses for Evan's team.
First one will be Sandra
Shine, who's Evan's assistant.
Thank you for your supports.
And I did look at your contest.
The pictures are very nice, very creative.
You put a lot of time in there.
Thank you for much and thank
you for the ongoing supports.
For the second bonus, it's J-Ryze.
He has filmed this video
with his roommate, Lynx.
They have laid out all
the books that J-Ryze
has purchased, he also
show the one that Evan's
given him with the message
and with the signature.
So, thank you, J-Ryze,
for the ongoing support.
We're going to give the One Word
book to your roommate, Lynx.
Thank you so much, guys, for watching.
So these are the top 10 people
I've picked for the contest,
and I hope you guys enjoyed
the book and enjoy the message
Evan will be putting on the book.
Bye.
- So that's it.
Those are our winners.
Thank you guys so much
for all of your entries.
I'm humbled, and I really,
really appreciate you pouring
your art into expressing
something for your one word,
and I hope that the book is
having an impact on your life.
For the winners, make sure to
contact me, shoot me an email,
send me a message on YouTube.
I need your address.
I need your full name, or
whatever you want to be
in the book, need to have
a little bit of detail.
Send it off to me, I'll make sure the book
gets sent off to you.
I've got some more fun book
stuff in the coming weeks,
so stay tuned.
I look forward to giving
you guys the update,
but until then, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.